hey everybody welcome to Channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world
and pop culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Ruth and I'm Ayanna Wayne
and this is your news for Monday
December 11 we're gonna start today off
with some casting news a little bit of a
strange choice at first Ryan Reynolds is
going to be playing detective Pikachu in
a movie titled detective Pikachu so he
is the titular character there and seems
like an odd choice at first bit of a
weird choice it seems strange I know a
lot of people are upset but it's not
Danny DeVito
yes he's not my detective Pikachu um
it's gonna be a live-action film when
yeah he was like as odd thing to begin
with
it's obviously based off the game
detective Pikachu in which Pikachu does
talk so Ryan Reynolds will be doing some
real speaking and acting as Pikachu per
se not so many pika pika
but yeah we know American audiences have
some problems with it wasn't great
wasn't great I think this movie could be
interesting if it was done like a Who
Framed Roger Rabbit style where there is
actual sell Animation Show for the live
action I think that would look really
interesting because obviously Pokemon is
an animated series like that so I would
rather see it go in that direction then
like a weird creepy CGI thing I could
get behind that I get that yeah yeah
so I mean we have no other details about
this besides it's live-action we got
Ryan Reynolds there's two other cast
members as well that the human
protagonists have been cast as well
because this Pikachu detective Pikachu
can only speak to certain people so he's
not gonna be speak
to all people just certain humans at
least the Swede is in the game right
we'll just have to show maybe maybe
that's not the case many people miss
Ryan Reynolds Lane pikachu was a buddy
cop film it's odd don't worry it gets
stranger yes speaking of other strange
things may happen this week Quentin
Tarantino might be directing a Star Trek
movie how would that work I don't know I
mean I would work with a lot of gore and
go yeah absolutely wearing I mean it
would be I can't imagine they would want
Quentin Tarantino to direct it without
his signature style right attached to it
I mean I guess they're trying to just
throw things at the wall after the last
Star Trek movie didn't do too great
maybe we need like a real cool
western-style Ferengi film maybe maybe
and I mean at this point it seems like
it has gone past the pitch there have
been reports that JJ Abrams has sat down
in a writing room okay with Quentin
Tarantino to just discuss it hash it out
see where it could go and one of the
things that gets me excited about this
is Patrick Stewart has said that he
would come back to the Star Trek
franchise to work with Tarantino okay
I've watched that which would be amazing
ya heart is my captain love that that
would be amazing tonight
so what I would being r-rated definitely
we are rated I can't see you doing a
Tarantino film without that kind of I
would like to see that I challenge you
telling you to make a pg-13 tunes you
know them take my challenge Tarantino me
a definite somebody James great we'll
just have to wait for more news from
that we also this week saw a trailer for
Alita battle angel it was a weird
trailer I gotta say it's a it's a manga
adaptation that James Cameron has been
trying to do for a while now it's gonna
be directed by Robert Rodriguez and the
main like character in this is a cyborg
animation style its we so weird CGI that
got going on on her so her eyes are huge
I kind of would get that if all the
other cyborgs were also huge eyes right
Annie Valli thing right right
it's just her I don't get that yeah
strange very strange to me but the
action sequences look pretty cool I yeah
I got a wait to see more from this we
haven't told July of 2018 to actually
see the full film but you know for a
manga adaptation that's also cast
completely with the white cast yet again
I don't know I feel like I can
definitely wait on this one not super
excited I feel like you have to read the
manga again I ran out a while ago and I
feel like it would need a refresher
before I go in and see the movie or
maybe that would just make me mad
my a lot of moody movies taken over
those things tend to not be direct
translations still not over go
sufficient yeah yeah how about definite
Wow avoiding it if I got news for you
also this week we got a first look at
the new epic The Nutcracker and the four
realms I'll be honest really looking
forward to this I'm a love ballet of
love like cool scores and stuff and this
looks like it could have some real
potential everyone has already had their
takes whether it looks like us or Narnia
I mean it's covered in snow what we've
seen so far so that's pretty much Narnia
good parallel right so we've got some
Wonderland thrown in there some people
were seeing cotton candies since there's
four different realms and it's nice like
the the rulers are leaders of each of
those realms seem to be a kind of candy
based we got to see here a Knightley as
the sugarplum fairy
I think her wig looks more cotton candy
fairy in my opinion she's very pink but
you will see more from that soon I'm
sure we've also got Mackenzie Foy as
Clara in that picture
and
miron is apparently going to be playing
mother ginger she seems super excited in
interviews which is super adorable she's
like very honored to do this very cute
because have you seen what you've done
Helen we've done a lot you've done a lot
she's done something I'm feeling great
and then Morgan Freeman is perhaps who
I'm most excited for he's going to be
playing Drosselmeyer so I need some
Morgan Freeman in an eyepatch you better
have an eyepatch if you're not like what
are you and then obviously with the cast
that I have mentioned it seems like
there's not much dancing that's going to
be happening good are you not so we've
got misty Copeland that's going to be
joining the cast so I'm sure she's going
to be doing some dancing in it as well
yeah that's really cool obviously I
really enjoy that element yeah it's
gonna be cool to like look forward to
the score they've got to have a good
score classic Tchaikovsky right yeah
violinist being up here on the strings
so I'm really looking forward to that
score looking forward to seeing that
cast
I watched Nutcracker every year around
Christmas but there was a specific
Nutcracker that I loved my little VHS
tape was worn out here year round not
just around Christmas it was the Maurice
Sendak version I don't know if anyone
else is seen but there's some like like
images and then they go into the ballet
as well it's sort of like reading a
storybook version of it if you haven't
seen that version I don't even know if
you can get it anymore if you can let me
know or if anyone else has seen it I was
obsessed with it plus the Rat King like
giant head and then a bunch of other
little heads around him freaks me out as
a kid but in the best way yeah you
enjoyed being freaked out solutely uh
yeah yeah well I'm sure the internet
will find it for you yeah so yeah we got
our first look just in time for the
holidays we have to wait until next year
it comes out in November of 2018 okay
but you've got not ticket sales you're
ready yeah so right absolutely I love a
good epic yeah um
earlier this week we also saw the game
award yanking the 2017 Game Awards
which I watched a lot of fun watching it
and the big winner of the night was
breath of the wild so they won Game of
the Year as well as Best Direction best
game direction as well as best action
adventure game and then another game
that kind of took home a couple of
honors there was cup head which I have
yet to play which is awful because I've
heard just fantastic things about it
but it won best independent game and
best art direction and Best Debut
independent game because that was that
game company's first game and it hoping
to avoid accolades that it received so I
I do still have to get on top of it and
see it but eventually eventually okay it
only so many hours exactly same only so
many hours and then also the most
anticipated game award went to something
that I cannot wait to play which would
be the Last of Us part 2 what we need it
yeah where is it it's very highly
anticipated it's kinda wanna know I
think 2018 is now the the release year
for it I don't know I don't think I know
anymore I just want it we could be in
the near 2017 right we could do that
just make it happen
and then winner the anticipated game
there are a whole bunch of other games
that had new trailers or were newly
announced and I know one that you're
excited about
absolutely the big trailer for me of The
Game Awards was definitely death
stranding it was a bonkers trailer it
was insane we've seen some stuff from it
before but this was the like longest
thing we've seen so far from it
it's hideo kojima of course and we've
got motion capture from norman reedus
mackelson and Guillermo del Toro
so what yes okay hello yeah um also that
trailer was just a bunch of just I don't
even know I know well how do you
describe that trailer have you started
we've got like we monster aliens that
are like Slenderman II maybe you're
Hannibal hands for feet because we keep
seeing handprints but they look bipedal
what you can't breathe around
is there a like a like a toxic air or is
it like the sound of their breathing
strange um also they were being like
sucked in this in like quick mud yeah
quick mud it was like black almost like
tar yeah yeah um there's like so I'm
like like weird like sucking up Souls
matter stuff going on happening there
was a baby yes in like a backpack and
then also when someone's throat Dallas
knows what's happening every minute you
learned more things I actually had more
question right what was happening right
so this is one of those very anticipated
games we're still waiting we I think
we're waiting until 2020 I think is the
latest update
they just keep releasing little stuff
but don't worry none of it is spoilers
because I couldn't tell you we don't we
haven't even seen any gameplay here so
we don't know I know what what do we do
it is yeah um I would just watch it as a
movie from being totally honest cuz what
is that I'm I what did I want what did I
watch it's not 100% sure I loved it but
man it's been strange it was weird I'm
very highly anticipated yeah like we
said oh man yep so that's gonna close us
out from the Game Awards there were many
other games that write some great awards
you haven't checked it out I'm sure
there's yeah yeah there's a whole bunch
of other new games that were announced
absolutely yeah I'm excited
yeah so if there's anything we missed
from this week let us know in the
comments down below we know we only have
so much time to talk to you every week
so let us know what you'd like us to
cover next week and otherwise you can
let us know on social media or in the
comments down below where can people
find you on social media you can find me
on Twitter at Heather Ruth's Instagram
at a truce or twitch twitch TV slash
other roofs and as always you can find
me on Facebook as Ayana weed or
everywhere else it's awesome Ayanna let
us know in the comments down below or on
social media otherwise we will catch you
next week in the meantime can you beam
us up
you